[Laughter]
okay I can do this if it hurt is working
that is my balls up here and then my
dick is back here at my butt hairy
Sasquatch or man into a beautiful woman
without further ado my daughter now I
don't think I've ever been to a drag
show you're gonna be in one tomorrow
going straight to the top
drag queens drag culture I don't know
anything I will be your guide which
makes me your mother I don't really know
what that mean it's not biological all
right build a house is the family so
basically drag queens are like Game of
Thrones very much it's an art form you
know it's like you're an actor planer
world dude by day lady by night people
love drag so much more now I'm always
all about this so this is a competition
race I want to win this thing I know I'm
gonna be prettier than that you might
need more time on makeup what kind of
Queen would you want to be have you ever
seen like a blue-collar drag queen I'm
seen as a normal guy I have never
changed this haircut or you want to be
like oh [ __ ] crazy dirty Nicki Minaj
tois like Kesha
I can work with Kesha so we're gonna
make you old try I'm prone to hurting
myself
because I get to a test tree fell down
drunk and bloody and champagne I like
keeping on the character staying true to
a lady I really like baby pair but then
every now and then you get real late pop
into the key deep voice - he just looks
like a desert we're gonna turn you into
a bubblegum pop princess
the subtle waiter you sound real stupid
and I like it thank you ginger Vitus my
name is ginger Vitus I'm so sweet I'm
gonna give you a holiday but don't worry
I'll is there a woman that inspires me I
feel like a lot of the influences in my
life are male community listen to you I
don't like listen to pop I guess I'm
just like kind of silly and like a
little nerdy and - this has been
security I don't know how that
translates into drag you won't know how
you see yourself until you see yourself
in drag I say embrace the dash of
insecurity onstage hornucopia I got a
lot to give your cornucopia runneth over
in kind of crass I'm often hung over her
I just have zero filter ratchet I don't
want to be legit if I'm gonna be a woman
I'm gonna be a classy woman like my mom
where are my pants I have no idea what I
would call myself I was watching porn
and I got mine that way so are you
telling me I have to go home and watch
pornography you should and then I'll
know my drag name the first thing I
thought was [ __ ] Huckleberry Finn
sushi homemaker that's like sexist and
racist at the same time I never wore
heels mostly because my feet was are so
big I don't even understand why ladies
wearing heels okay it's a whole most
gross how perfect they are just give me
a little runway walk you could have gone
your whole life without heels oh I love
it though it adds to the walk it adds
the confidence they hurt so much
yeah but it's worth it there's no off my
toaster you know if you have not known
this page you see the girls after the
club closes and they're struggling to
get to the car I'm just gonna rest while
you talk there's the most special
torture devices make women move very
slowly yeah no kidding I ski
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes I do what no daughter of mine will
wear flats
I want to get the emotion out I want to
make the people cry so we were talking
about Robin dancing on my own how do you
feel about that I love that song okay
that song is all about feeling yeah so
it's really easy to sink into the
emotion of it you need to focus more on
being feminine I just want to blow this
house up up it's got to be a little bit
softer a little bit flirtier and then
from here down a little bit more over
the top yeah that's fun if you do that I
like for a song peacock oh you got it
yeah add like specifically or extra
specific moves it's more about the
essence of the song but you have a right
we're doing partition make love to the
work I can't do it I just have to think
I want to [ __ ] the / yeah so the morals
of lip-sync is he's wet and then it's
hard this has to go that has forgot all
of it yeah house it takes a shave a leg
how well-groomed should this area be I
get the pits and get them legs together
so I'm the only one showing lay show the
skin you want I'm trying to be a classy
lady
Oh hardwood floors work best we're
shaving up it and taking care of the
whiskey pits for sure look at this I
could put a weave in that Chester to the
neckline of the top and sideburns and
the back I don't even know what my skin
looks like anymore it's like I haven't
seen it it's the law I shaved a little
bit of Zach's chest hair that was a
mistake we don't pay enough half the
battle is when you transform when you
look like a different person isn't it
weird to think that glue sticks are most
commonly bought by elementary school
kids and drag queens you're
automatically gonna act affirm it I
really can't like this should be like an
Olympic sport there is a [ __ ] ton that
goes into it
ah nothing more than to just rub my eyes
look at her though what do you think our
founding fathers would say about this
this is like a skyscraper of makeup on
my face are there straight guys who do
drag then there's the fear of
compromising your masculine hunna brakes
need to tap out for sexy but who cares
so drag name I was thinking Cory an okay
again okay like it but I don't notice it
like I don't have breasts you know what
I have a lot of like flab that we can
maybe push around have kind of fun well
thankfully we ain't showing no cleavage
I've got hips for you this is how you
make an ass it's literally like
outstripping well there's a man shoving
foam into my butt you have to cover all
of the boy it's a little Lindsay Lohan
that could be good finish your [ __ ]
drinks [ __ ] body
Adi Adi he's a dick oh yeah
take your nut so you put them up in the
socket socket where they came from
before they drop just going upstairs
feel like I only have a split-level
house well your dick back yeah that's my
butt hole with my dick yeah I'm like a
bong how do you guys pee when you're
working you don't I'm gonna go tuck in
the bathroom [ __ ] oh my god I think
I did it
you're flat I'm flat guess who tucks
typical drag show would be a path one
out there and do their little dance me
get some winnings tonight we're gonna be
popping the cherry busted my doctorate
found herself right away I feel like we
can really surprise her with how like a
woman I could become her name is ginger
Biden
[Applause]
[Music]
Mista gave me so much more confidence
when it's like don't worry about getting
the words right so if you just sell
ginger Vitus to other people and you
connect with the audience members that's
all matter I love that the new you
throws himself into everything and she
was beautiful
this chick is you were all the treasure
I just want to warn the first row that
this could become a splash so where do I
think about the whole drag hood she
thinks it's funny champagne can
[Applause]
I thought it was gonna be kind of weird
and I would feel uncomfortable but once
you put all of this on you really become
a different person or at least you feel
like you are until your wig flies off
maybe fix your hat [ __ ]
[Applause]
how's everyone doing tonight my sisters
they are both judgmental
gritty the most cutthroat Asian girls
only my daughter Cheyenne
[Applause]
physically this is torture on my body my
toes are crushed my balls and dick have
disappeared somewhere within me I am
sweating under this wig I feel like
there's 20 pounds of makeup on my face
and yet there's like a rush to it which
is really cool what'd you think of the
show I'm finally the prettiest sister
[Applause]
now before I free my daughter I do
unlike the other performers it's not a
[ __ ] I can't just like be a half-ass
track for my grandma I got to do this so
give it up for cornucopia corn fell I
didn't even know who you were she's been
such a great job and I didn't know you
had such fantastic way oh thank you Jeff
for drag queens they are both better men
they have been better with the design
who do you think he resembles to pick
somebody whose father
[Applause]
[Music]
you